sean fx igual a 5 / x y gtx igual al
valor absoluto de x 4 esto menos 3 las
gráficas de ye igual a fx y de yale a la
gtx están abajo
de hecho las podemos ver aquí y bueno si
observas fx es esta que tengo de color
morado es más déjenme poner la de color
morado esta es fx déjame ponerle así
esta es fx la que tengo de color morado
justo la tengo aquí de igual a fx y
bueno es esta y esta parte de aquí pero
por otra parte también tengo allí igual
hdx de color azul gx es toda esta
función que tengo aquí y bueno me dicen
que quien iguala gdx también la tengo
representada aquí abajo de color azul
muy bien después me dicen el punto y
coma p está en la gráfica de las
funciones
efe
y lo podemos ver claramente aquí en este
punto como ven está tanto en la función
de la gtx como en la función de igual a
fx y eso quiere decir que tenemos un
punto de intersección y lo podemos ver
aquí
aquí tenemos nuestro punto de
intersección entonces podemos decir que
cuando x es igual a am la función fx
toma el valor de bme y la función gtx
toma el valor de bm o bueno eso es una
forma de decirlo porque otra forma de
decirlo es pensar que en este punto que
tengo aquí déjame hacer una gran flecha
para que lo veas en ese punto de jim se
cumplen qué
efe aam que f de am va a ser exactamente
igual va a ser exactamente igual qué
de a kg
muy bien y bueno esto a su vez es igual
a ave déjame ponerlo con este color es
igual a ver esto en el punto de
intersección y bueno ya con esto podemos
decir lo siguiente porque si sustituimos
a x por el valor de amd en esta función
que me quedaría bueno me va a quedar lo
siguiente
puedo decir que 55 entre a esto es f de
am va a ser igual que gta pero g de am
quien es bueno sustituyendo a a por x en
esta ecuación me quedaría el valor
absoluto de amd menos 4 ok ya esto le
quitamos 3 estas dos expresiones son
iguales y son iguales
avn porque estamos en nuestro punto de
intersección que es un punto que
pertenece a ambas funciones cuando x
vale a bueno y ya con esto podemos ver
que nos preguntan bajemos la pantalla de
ambrós nos dicen el valor x igual a am
es solución de cuáles de las siguientes
ecuaciones selecciona todas las opciones
correctas y primero me dicen se
encuentra x es igual a b ahora lo que
nosotros sí sabemos es que cinco déjame
ponerlo así con este color que 5 entre a
esto sabemos que es igual
avn sabemos que es igual a b
pero aquí observa esta que tengo aquí es
mi función
efe de x
esta que tengo aquí es mi función fx
déjenme ponerlo así
efe de equis pero ojo lo que me están
diciendo es que x vale a esto es muy
importante me están diciendo que x vale
por lo tanto f de x cuando x balear es
lo mismo que pensar en f de am y ya
sabemos que cuando x balear
efe de am es igual a b y por lo tanto si
f de am es igual a b
puedo decir que esta sería una opción
correcta cuando x baila así que déjame
poner que ésta sí es una opción correcta
y vamos a ver la siguiente opción el
valor absoluto de x menos 4 esto a su
vez menos 3 es igual a b bueno pues eso
también lo sabemos deja de subir un poco
la pantalla si recuerdas acá arriba
estaba diciendo que queda también vale y
aquí lo que nos dicen es que equivale a
por lo tanto esta sería la definición
de gea déjame ponerlo con su respectivo
color esto de aquí lo que me está
diciendo es gtx cbx pero recuerda que
nos estamos fijando en el valor de x
igual a am por lo tanto esto sería lo
mismo que el valor absoluto de a menos 4
menos 3 y eso sabemos que es igual a ver
justo lo que nos dice aquí por lo tanto
también puedo seleccionar esta opción
correcta y de lujo ya tenemos las dos
opciones correctas la última nos decía
ninguna de las anteriores y por lo tanto
esa no es la opción correcta son estas
dos de aquí arriba y ya hemos acabado